[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a french drama fantasy
film called angel spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
louise is a beautiful young girl working
as an assistant to a magician she falls
in love with his charm and so does he
with her beauty but tragedy strikes when
during one of their performances the
magician depicts being invisible and
never returns his disappearance causes
louise to fall into a spiral of
depression for some reason she believes
he will return to her soon because he
has the ability to turn invisible on
command her depression turns into
hallucinations and delusion which
eventually lands her in a mental asylum
nine months after the magician's
disappearance louise goes into labor no
one knows she is pregnant so she has to
give birth on her own the baby born that
night is invisible his existence proves
that louise is not delusional or maybe
it proves she's really delusional but
either way she is too scared to tell the
nurses she knows her son will turn into
a subject of experiments if people find
out about his existence hence she keeps
him a secret the nurses come every day
to give her food and medicine but never
find out about the invisible kid living
in the room luis calls him angel which
eventually turns into his name she takes
great care of him and raises him like
any normal child we see her patting his
back feeding him teaching him to talk
and eat when he grows old enough she
uses chalk and the wall to teach him to
read angel loves to play with louise's
old dress and shoes which is the only
way he can see half of himself in the
mirror every night louise tells him
about her childhood home she used to
live in a cabin in the middle of the
woods owned by her father on vacation
they used to travel by train and go to a
lake it is louise's favorite place in
the world and she hopes her son will be
able to see it one day she also wants to
teach him to swim in the lake but the
thought of him meeting the outside world
scares her to death
on his birthdays louise lights up rolled
pages and puts them on top of two slices
of bread to mimic a cake angel doesn't
know any better hence he never complains
as the years pass angel grows up to be a
smart 10 year old but doesn't come to
terms with his invisibility with growing
age his curiosity grows as well one
evening he gets on top of a chair and
looks outside the window for the first
time in his life he sees another human
his age a little girl is with her
parents outside her home she trips on
the stairs and is helped by her mother
angel returns to his mother in bed and
tells her about the girl louise is
terrified that her son is growing
curious about the outside world she
tells him he is different from the rest
of the world which the normal people
don't like hence he has to be careful to
never be noticed by anyone the comment
makes a lasting impression on the kid
but his interest in the pretty neighbor
doesn't die he frequently watches her
through the window and realizes she
always plays the same two keys on the
piano he listens to it for as long as he
can hoping to meet her someday one
morning angel asks his mother what it is
like to see herself in the mirror louise
describes the feeling as seeing yourself
a little more than you see other people
louise always believed that her lover
would come to her and angel one day but
after years of waiting she has fallen
deep into depression she barely talks to
angel nowadays when she pulls away from
him he feels lonely and spends days
drawing on the wall one day the pretty
girl looks directly at him from the
garden in front of her house angel feels
nervous and runs to tell his mother who
turns away without saying a word later
louise is brought outside her room by
the nurses angel takes the opportunity
to run outside without being noticed he
walks on the grass away from the cold
marbled floor for the first time in his
life a few minutes later he ends up in
front of the pretty girl who is playing
on a swing she feels his presence and
asks him to come closer a stunned angel
asks if she can see him and finds out
she is blind her sense of smell and
touch is heightened which is why she can
feel his presence nearby angel who has
never seen himself before feels like he
exists for the first time the girl
introduces herself as madeline and
touches his hand they talk for a minute
before angel gets nervous madeline makes
him promise that he will come again
before he runs away she has no friends
because of her disability so talking to
someone her own age is as delightful for
her as it is for angel he returns to the
room with the nurses and lays beside his
mother by now louise has stopped smiling
altogether angel tells her he has a
girlfriend but she shows no reaction he
goes to meet madeline again as soon as
he can she touches his face and can see
him clearly in her imagination angel
also tells her that he watches her from
the window and loves to hear her play
the piano madeline laughs because she
only uses two keys and has never played
a melody the two play hide and seek for
hours even though one of them is
invisible and the other is blind soon
the two become inseparable and angel
starts spending most of his days with
her one day they take a step forward and
kiss madeline can perfectly guess what
part of her body angel is looking at
because she can feel his gaze i may not
be able to see out of them but my eyes
are up here buddy angel couldn't be
happier in life but that doesn't last
long madeline reveals that she is about
to get eye surgery the next week after
which she will be able to see she is the
most excited about finally getting to
see angel but he doesn't feel the same
way they spend the next week together
before she waves at him from her house
and leaves that night louise speaks for
the first time in months and invites
angel to sleep by her side she also asks
him to go to the cabin in the woods if
something ever happens to her when angel
wakes up in the morning she has already
passed away the news is too much for the
kid to take he watches his mother's body
for hours before the nurses come and
take her away they also remove all of
her belongings and the writing from the
wall the room is the only thing angel
ever knew apart from madeline it is gone
and madeline will hate him when she
finds out the truth so without anything
in his possession he boards a train and
goes to the lake his mother always
talked about he imagines madeline coming
out of the water which only makes him
sadder then he boards another train to
the cabin in the woods he breaks in and
looks around before sleeping on the sofa
and declaring it his house weeks turn
into months and months into years angel
is now a grown man evident from his
raspy and manly voice he has only talked
to himself for years but still hopes he
will get to see madeline someday then
finally one day she arrives at the cabin
angel feels like he is in a dream and
cannot stop looking at her he stands
right in front of her but even with her
recovered eyes madeline doesn't see him
for the next two days she goes around
the nearest town and asks people about
him it turns out she has been looking
for him since she returned from the
hospital madeline knew about his mother
but the asylum had no records of his
existence hence she did more research
about louise and found out about the
cabin that day she also visits louise's
grave and leaves a letter for angel it
says that she is back and asks him to
come to her angel continues following
her and stays with her at the house
without her knowing madeline frequently
feels his eyes on him like she did years
ago but she dismisses it every single
time having had enough angel writes a
letter back to her saying that he misses
her as much as she misses him but can
only meet if she promises to keep her
eyes closed they meet in the woods later
that day and as promised madeline keeps
her eyes closed they return home
together and lay down by each other's
side madeline feels his face and takes
in his scent trying to relive the
memories they shared his scent has
changed a little but she can still
recognize him the lovers are overwhelmed
by the sudden closeness after years of
longing for each other in the following
scene madeline is blindfolded and naked
with angel on the bed angel asks her how
she felt when she first regained her
vision madeline describes it as a
strange experience before she thought
the things in the room only existed when
she touched them a bouncy ball would
disappear from the face of the earth
when she threw it at the wall and then
it would reappear again when it touched
her hands but when she gained her vision
she realized the ball was always there
similarly she found out that many things
in her room exist simultaneously not
just when she touches them the profound
explanation makes angel question his
existence when he is away from madeline
for the next week they live in paradise
madeline continuously has a cloth over
her eyes but doesn't mind it they talk
about their childhood and their teen
years and end up falling in love for the
second time then angel brings her to see
the lake which has become his favorite
place over the years madeline takes off
the blindfold and is mesmerized by the
view but the only thing she really wants
to see is her boyfriend's face angel
kisses her on the neck from behind and
promises to reveal himself at night the
night comes and he is in the bedroom
with a sheet over his head madeline
promises to love him no matter what he
looks like but when she takes the sheet
off she retreats in shock angel tells
her the truth which is too much for her
to take she breaks down crying making
angel feel like the ugliest person in
the world he watches her curl up on the
floor in tears till the morning when she
falls asleep on the ground he puts a
blanket over her it wakes madeline up
from her sleep she says she is ready to
keep her eyes closed for life if it
means they can be together but angel
doesn't want that he doesn't say
anything to her face but registers that
she has to be blind to actually love him
madeline wakes up the next morning and
looks for angel but doesn't find him
instead she finds a note that says he is
going away from her life he promises to
always love her but asks her to stop
loving him madeline sheds a single tear
after reading it she packs her luggage
and is ready to leave when she feels
something in her chest it is almost as
if she can tell where angel is at that
moment after closing her eyes and
searching for his scent she realizes he
went to the lake in the following scene
madeline reaches the deck and calls for
him she knows he is nearby because of
his scent but angel refuses to talk
suddenly a splash of water is heard
angel has accidentally fallen into the
lake but he doesn't know how to swim
madeline jumps behind him even though
she cannot see him after frantically
searching for a while she sees bubbles
underwater and brings him to the shore
angel gains consciousness after a few
rounds of cpr madeline declares that
this is the end of their misery and they
will remain together forever after this
moment she promises to learn to see him
with her eyes open like she used to see
him with them closed in the following
montage we see the couple living a happy
life together they play fight talk and
make love like any normal couple
sometimes madeline puts makeup on angel
and they laugh at the absurd result
eventually she gets pregnant and gives
birth to a visible baby the couple
starts their own magic show which
becomes a hit in the last scene we see
them swimming together
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching